JAY BLAKESBERG: Hey, everybody.
Thanks for coming out and
spending your time with me.
I appreciate it.
My name is Jay Blakesberg,
and I'm a photographer.
And I live in San Francisco, and
I do a lot of video work, also.
And most of my career has
been in the music industry
as a photographer.
You know, you hear about people
all the time saying, God,
I want to be a
rock photographer.
And somehow I pulled it off.
So it's been pretty good ride.
So, I grew up in New
Jersey, suburban New Jersey,
and I went to high
school in the 1970s.
I went to high school
from '75 to '79,
classic dazed and
confused years.
And this is in upstate
New York, actually.
This is my best friend from high
school, moved up to upstate New
York, and we used to go up
there every weekend we could
and get wasted.
And that's me as a young
teenager-- that's about 1978.
And we would party, like any
other teenager in the 1970s.
We didn't have the internet.
We were young, stupid teenagers.
And this picture, when I put it
on Facebook a couple weeks ago
for a throwback Thursday,
got a lot of attention.
People really liked the fact
that I was smoking marijuana.
And then, in 1977, my sister
took me to my first Grateful
Dead concert, and nothing
has been the same sense.
This is me at Englishtown, which
was a very famous Grateful Dead
concert, Labor Day weekend 1977.
There were 100,000 people
that came to this concert.
And pretty
life-changing experience
for me, which we'll get
into as time goes on.
Not because I'm passed out
with a bong on my stomach,
but just because of the journey
that I've taken with that.
And yes, what a long,
strange trip it has been,
and continues to be so.
This is my very,
very first photograph
that was ever published
in a magazine.
And it was published
in Relix magazine
and that is Jorma Kaukonen, from
the Jefferson Airplane and Hot
Tuna.
And Hot Tuna had just broken
up-- this was taken in 1978.
And-- I need a couple
of dates here--
and it was a solo
concert for Jorma.
It was billed as Hot Tuna
but Hot Tuna had just broken,
up Jorma played
it solo acoustic.
And I was 16 years old.
And we drove up with
a friend of mine
who was a senior in high school.
And he had a little Carmen
Ghia-- you know, those little,
Volkswagen Carmen Ghias?
And me and my friend, Nicky, who
were about this big back then,
sat in the back.
And after the
concert, we decided
we were going to follow
Jorma's limo into New York City
to meet Jorma, because
we were 16 and stupid.
And so, we followed him in.
And he stopped at a
delicatessen to get some food.
I went in there.
I had my brother's camera
that I had borrowed,
and I said, hey, Jorma,
how about a picture?
And I got this picture.
And then I send
it in as a letter
to the editor in Relix magazine.
Relix is still around today.
And they published it
with my little story
about following Jorma
into New York City.
And that was my very
first photograph
that was ever published-- but
not paid for-- as a letter
to the editor.
Jorma, who still
makes music today,
is a good friend of mine.
We talk and
communicate regularly,
and I still go shoot
him and go to his shows.
That's me graduating
from high school.
So that previous photo
was in November of '78.
This is in June of '79.
I don't know if
you can see there,
I've got a Grateful
Dead skull and roses
patch on my graduation gown.
And then, right after
high school was over,
I was starting to bring
my camera to concerts.
And this to me is a
very iconic photo.
This was taken-- I
believe in June of '79--
at Radio City Music Hall.
And this is BB King,
James Cotton, Muddy Water,
and Johnny Winter.
And these are like, you know,
the guys in blues music.
And you know, I think out
of the roll or two of film
that I shot, I think this
is the only shot that's
really, actually in focus
and exposed properly.
I was still trying
to figure it all out.
Back then, we didn't
have digital cameras,
so you actually had to know
how to expose film, and develop
film, and whatnot.
Another photo that I
took a couple months
after graduating high school,
Crosby, Stills and Nash,
Madison Square Garden,
September of '79.
This was at the big
No Nukes concerts
that they did back then.
And it's sort of indicative
of how everything--
how valuable
intellectual property is.
You know, people say, what
do you do for a living?
And depending on who you
are, I might say, well,
I create intellectual
property and license it
across multiple platforms.
Which is really what
I do, but I do it
with photography and video.
So Stephen Stills used,
not this exact shot,
but one similar in color
for his new box set
that just came out six
months ago or whatever.
So here's a photo
that I took just
out of high school in
1979, 35 years ago,
that still has value today
as intellectual property.
This is me at a Grateful
Dead concert in 1980,
so I was starting
to kind of come out
as a full blown hippie.
And by 1981, I was the full
blown, sophisticated, groovy
hippie on Grateful Dead
tour that I am today.
Few years later, I
kind of was laying low,
wasn't doing much photography,
I moved to Olympia, Washington
and I went to the
Evergreen State College.
And after I graduated
from Evergreen in '85,
I believe it was, I
was back up in Seattle
visiting some friends.
And I went to this
concert, which
was the band X. It was actually
X and the Red Hot Chili
Peppers.
This is at the Moore
Theater up in Seattle.
And I just love this
shot because this guy--
this stage was
really high, you can
see from their faces-- I mean,
this guy he came crashing down
on these people like
from 15 feet in the air.
So, shortly after that I
became a house photographer
at a nightclub in San
Francisco on Haight Street
called the I-Beam.
The I-Beam doesn't
exist anymore,
that whole block was
knocked down and rebuilt.
And this is actually
Chris Cornell
from Soundgarden stage
diving at that show.
And this is in
1989, when I think
just before "Louder
Than Love" came out.
Soundgarden's sound
man at the time
was my college roommate
at Evergreen before that.
He actually grew up
with a couple of guys
from Soundgarden.
He has a big recording
studio in Seattle to this day
that everybody's recorded in.
Another shot of Chris Cornell.
And then, this is the
same show, and that's
Eric Johnson, who was their
tour manager and merch
guy at the time-- he's actually
Neil Young's tour manager now
and has been for the
last 12, 15 years.
After working for
Soundgarden, he
started working for Pearl Jam,
and then Neil stole him away.
Another shot from the I-Beam.
Just a crowd shot.
This concert, the
band was called
The Godfather, who
are a British band.
They had one big hit, I think
it was called "Love Work, Taxes
Death", something like that.
Something like Birth, School,
Taxes, Death-- Birth, School,
Work, Death--
something like that.
Anyway, you know, a lot
of craziness at the I-Beam
and I got crushed
frequently at that club.
And they only had live
music on Monday nights
at the I-Beam,
which was very odd.
And the other nights
on the weekends,
it was a gay dance club,
which was very odd.
But they had all
sorts of great bands.
Butthole Surfers-- this
is actually at the I-Beam,
but it was the I-Beam West.
They have like-- did a
few shows south of Market
at some warehouse that
is now some dot com
or something like that.
This is Nirvana, taken
up on Haight Street,
before Dave Grohl
was in the band.
This is before
"Nevermind" came out,
and they were doing an
in-store at Rough Trade
Records on Haight Street.
I invited them back
to a photo studio
afterwards, on their
way to Sacramento,
to do a band portrait.
And they got lost
and never found it,
and called me from Sacramento
hours later like, sorry, dude,
we're not coming.
So I never got to do a portrait
of Nirvana, unfortunately.
This sort of the
beginning of my big break.
This is U2 during the
filming of "Rattle and Hum."
and that's me over
there with the camera.
And this was taken
into a mirror.
When they were filming
"Rattle and Hum,"
they came to the
Mission District.
And they were touring
a bunch of murals.
And this is at the
Mission Cultural Center.
And this guy right
here, his name
is Rene Castro and
his wife, Deborah.
Deborah worked at Sammy's Camera
in the city-- which is now
back, it was Pro
Camera for a while.
And I was friends with her.
And this guy, Dave, was
friends with Bono and The Edge.
And Rene was a famous
artist in Chile
who was kidnapped and tortured
by the government back
in the '70s.
And then Amnesty
International released him.
And obviously U2 was big
with the whole Amnesty thing.
And so they came
and toured this.
Another shot of Bono from
visiting in the Mission Culture
Center.
This is November of 1987.
And then, a couple
days later, they
did a free concert in
downtown San Francisco,
which was in "Rattle and Hum."
And if you go watch the
movie, I'm the guy down front
with the Nikon and the
mullet, you can't miss me.
But the really important thing
about this particular shot
is, this was my very
first assignment
for "Rolling Stone"
magazine in print.
I've done over 300 assignments
for "Rolling Stone" magazine
in print.
And this is the shot that
ran in "Rolling Stone"
and I was literally--
the sound system
for this free concert was the
Grateful Dead sound system.
And so, there was a lot of buzz
going around in that circle
that this was going to happen.
And I got a phone call
from a friend of mine,
he's like, free U2
concert, it's happening,
today, now, Justin Herman plaza.
And I was putting all
my camera stuff together
to take BART into the
city, and the phone rang.
And it's like, hey
Jay, this is Jodi--
Jodi Peckman is still the photo
editor at "Rolling Stone"--
I have your big break for you.
And she assigned me to
shoot this free concert.
And that was my first photo
in "Rolling Stone" magazine.
This is The Pixies,
also, in 1988.
Going back to the
I-Beam again, this
is one of the just quick,
little backstage snapshots
that I did flash-on-camera.
And the thing that is so great
about it is, three months ago,
The Pixies hired me to do
their new publicity photos
for their next
whole album cycle.
So we spent-- this was I think
in February of this year,
just a couple
months ago-- and we
spent three, four
hours in Alameda.
They played The Fox in
Oakland the night before,
and they were playing in
San Jose the next day.
And we did all new publicity
photos of The Pixies.
And I showed them that picture.
It's in my book-- one
of the ones that's
out here in the hallway-- and
they were just blown away.
And it's just amazing that
it's now 25 years later, like
that, you know?
"BAM" magazine was
a magazine here
in the Bay Area for many,
many, many years, decades-- all
through the '70s,
all through the '80s.
It was a newsprint magazine.
It stood for Bay Area Music.
They eventually did
an edition down in LA.
They used to have a
music awards thing
called the BAMies, the
Bay Area Music Awards.
That was super fun.
This was my first magazine
cover that I shot for them.
I had been starting
to shoot some stuff.
I basically walked in, met
with the editor, and said,
I want to shoot covers for you.
I had never shot a
magazine cover before.
And this is the first one
they did-- they assigned me.
And this was Camper
Van Beethoven,
shot down in Santa Cruz.
Red Hot Chili Peppers--
this was a "BAM" cover.
These next few are
all "BAM" covers.
This was actually
shot at The Film,
or upstairs in the balcony
there, I set up a backdrop.
And 1989, just some of my
favorite-- I mean, these-- you
know, Flea and Anthony look like
babies in these pictures here.
But some of my favorite
Chili Pepper shots.
This is the band, Primus.
This is my first
shoot with Primus.
And this is-- we're going to do,
I think, questions afterwards,
at the end.
So write them down
or remember them.
So Primus, I've had a really,
super-long relationship with,
which we'll get into a little
bit later in the presentation.
But this was my first
shoot with them.
And it was a "BAM" cover.
Less is really into
boating and fishing,
and so we met at the dock.
This is his boat
in San Pablo Bay.
I believe that's the actual
cover shot they used.
I had them ride in their
boat, and as Less tells it,
he says that I kept telling
them to come closer to the dock
until he smashed his boat.
But I just think it was
his bad boat-riding,
but he blames me to this day.
Another cover with Iggy
Pop for "BAM" magazine.
And you know, Iggy had
this leather jacket on,
and I was like-- you know,
I had 20 minutes with Iggy--
and I'm like, will you
take the jacket off?
And he's like,
"er, um, fuck you."
You know.
And then, like,
two minutes later,
he's like, "OK, fuck it."
You know, I'll take
the jacket off.
So that's how we started,
with a jacket and a shirt.
Then he took the shirt
off, put the jacket on.
A little before-- you know,
eventually he was bare chested.
Because, you know, Iggy's got
that gnarly-- if you've ever
seen a picture of
Iggy, you know he's
got that gnarly, gnarly body.
Jellyfish-- I don'
t know if you guys
remember Jellyfish,
great power pop band.
My first photo shoot
with Carlos Santana.
I've gone on to do a 25-year
relationship with him
and working with him.
I love working with Carlos.
Ice-T-- for awhile
there, they decided
that they were
going to put my name
and the writer's name
on the cover of "BAM"
every time there was a story.
So it would say, written
by Steve Stolder,
photographs by Jay Blakesberg.
And when we did
this Ice-T cover,
my name was bigger than Ice-T's.
And after that issue,
they didn't put our names
on the cover anymore.
Jane's Addiction--
this was right
before the very
Lollapalooza in 1991.
They were doing a
short, little tour.
This is up in Sacramento.
And these guys hated each other.
I mean, you know, Eric, the
bass player in the back,
and Dave wouldn't talk to Perry.
Everybody talked to the drummer,
Stephen Perkins, the guy
in the upper right.
But the band did not
get along at all.
And they just were not
happy to be doing it.
And they were even unhappy--
there was an Almost Famous
moment-- when the
cover story came out,
it was just Perry on the cover.
So, do you remember that scene
in "Almost Famous" were like,
the singer's like in the lead on
the t-shirt and everybody else
is way in the background?
It was like one
of those moments.
But they were just
all super unhappy.
And I think Dave Navarro
was eating a cookie.
And I said, "Can you
put the cookie away?"
And he goes, "Fuck you, dude.
This is my time, not yours."
You know?
And so, it was like
super, super tense.
And then, that's like something
that they ran on the cover--
could've been that one
or something similar.
Spinal Tap-- I got
to see Spinal Tap.
This is a "BAM" magazine cover.
We shot this in the conference
room at MCA Records.
They were giving
away promo material.
It's like a Spinal Tap joke.
They said, you know,
to the record company,
"We want to do limited edition
calendars, calendars" right?
You know, they wanted calendars
with pictures on them.
But the label thought they
were saying "colander",
so they made
limited-edition colanders.
[LAUGHTER]
JAY BLAKESBERG:
I still have one.
I have like a little
metal colander.
It's got a ticket
on it, you know,
on a chain that says,
limited edition, one of 200,
or something like that.
Pretty funny.
Cracker, who was the guy
from Camper Van Beethoven--
another "BAM Magazine" cover.
Blind Melon, before
Shannon Hoon went off
and accidentally overdosed
and killed himself.
Counting Crows-- this was
also a big cover for me--
this was in 1993.
And this was their
first magazine cover,
a cover of "BAM."
But the thing that was great
about this particular day
is that, after I did this
shoot, I want up to Mill Valley
to David Grisman's house
and did a magazine cover
with Jerry Garcia
and David Grisman
for "Acoustic Guitar" Magazine.
So a big day for me
to be doing that.
Sheryl Crowe-- I also shot
her first magazine cover,
which was for "BAM."
When that big, first
record came out,
the "Tuesday Night Music Club",
her first single they released
was "Run, Baby, Run", if you
go back and listen to it.
And it did nothing at radios
before the next song, which
was "Leaving Las
Vegas", I believe
is the name of that song.
And they didn't know
what to do with her,
but they decided to put
her on the cover of "BAM."
She came there, no hair,
no makeup, no stylist.
Her and her manager-- who
is still her manager today--
he ignored me, we shot for
an hour, and that was it,
her first magazine cover.
Same with Alanis
Morissette-- this
is right before
"Jagged Little Pill."
Actually, "Jagged, Little Pill"
had just come out this week,
and it sold like 10 copies.
This was before she exploded.
And so it was a "BAM" magazine
cover and at the same time,
we shot a cover for another
magazine called "Request."
So I got two magazine covers
out of that same shoot.
Third Eye Blind-- I have
a long term relationship
with these crazy people.
I've been shooting
them since day one.
And that's sort of like
the wrap up of "BAM."
I think there's another 10 or
20 magazine covers in there,
but I didn't want
to bore you anymore.
So back to the
Grateful Dead, which
of course is the
life-changing experience.
They're not the best
at what they do,
they're the only ones
that do what they do.
And it's certainly true.
I tapped into the
Grateful Dead early on.
And I was a hippie on tour.
You saw the pictures
early in the presentation,
and I lived the life.
You know, we went on tour, we
smoked marijuana, we did LSD,
we saw a lot of Grateful Dead
concerts, we had a lot of fun.
This one in here was my
girlfriend at the time.
And just recently,
this photo ran
in "Rolling Stone" magazine.
About a year ago, they
did a special issue
on the Grateful Dead.
And they wanted to run
this photo, which they did.
And they called me
up, and they said,
we need some caption info.
Do you have any caption info?
And I was like, "yeah, you
know, the girl's name is Tammy.
She's from Monterey, California.
It was taken on
September 6-- I think
it was-- 1980 in
Lewiston, Maine.
And her father was a
Colonel in the Air Force,
and we kidnapped her and took
her on Grateful Dead tour.
You know.
A little bit more information
than they were expecting.
More deadheads from that show.
We lived in hotel rooms.
And you know, this
to me was sort
of the beginning of what I
consider really what I do.
Which is, I do
visual anthropology.
You know, anthropology,
the definition
is the study of humankind.
And this was a great
subject matter,
to have a bunch of freaks
to be able to photograph.
This is my wife, over
here on the left.
We were not married at
the time this photograph.
I met her at a
Grateful Dead concert.
Still married today.
Ample opportunities to
photograph people having fun,
losing their minds at a
Grateful Dead concert.
Like I said, just a great
anthropological study
of this culture.
And now, you know, this
picture was taken in 1986
at the Greek Theatre--
and I've been
posting a lot of this
stuff on Facebook.
And the response--
like, I can post
a picture of Jerry
Garcia on Facebook
and get a few thousand
views or whatever.
I'll put something
like this on Facebook,
and 10,000, 20,000
people will look at it
and be freaking out,
because this stuff is just
so classic now that
it's 25 years old.
Good friend of mine, Jennifer.
And people are always
saying, why don't you
have any pictures of
me when you were taking
pictures of deadheads back then?
I'm like, because you all
thought I worked for the DEA,
and you all ran away from me
when I took my camera out.
And all the pictures are
people of my friends.
These are all people
I was on tour with,
and I was hanging out with, and
eating dinner with, and living
in hotel rooms
with, and so those
are the people in
my photographs.
So this is my very
first interaction
with a Grateful
Dead band member.
This is Bob Weir and Brent
Mydland from the Grateful
Dead-- guitar, singer and
keyboard player-- and this
was in May of 1979.
I was 17 years old.
And I convinced my
mother that I was
going to drive to Virginia,
six hours away from New Jersey,
with some stranger to go
see the Grateful Dead.
And she let me go.
Go figure, I'm not letting
my daughter do that.
She's 18.
No way.
And anyway, so the day
after the show in Virginia,
there was a big,
giant no nukes rally
on the front steps
of the capital.
And Joni Mitchell played,
Jackson Browne played,
bunch of different people.
And I was walking around and I
found one of those little staff
badges on the ground.
It said press.
And I walked backstage,
and I was backstage.
You know, I was 17 years old.
And I ran into Bob
Weir and Brent Mydland,
who were playing in Baltimore,
I think, later that night.
Except for the guy I was
driving down with from Virginia,
he was so drunk after
the show in Virginia,
he actually totalled his car
pulling out of the parking lot,
and we hitchhiked to Baltimore.
So here I am, 17,
hitchhiking to Baltimore,
and then hitchhiking
home to New Jersey
after the show in Baltimore.
But that's just the way we
rolled, because we had to.
More deadhead stuff.
OK, so this was a "Rolling
Stone" magazine assignment.
Slightly after that U2 one.
Benefit concert
that Bill Graham put
on-- that's Bob Weir,
Bill Graham, and Jerry
Garcia-- at the Kaiser.
And it was members of the
Grateful Dead, Bonnie Raitt,
Carlos Santana,
and this was maybe
my second or third-- I think it
was my second "Rolling Stone"
magazine assignment.
Just some classic shots.
This is probably my most
iconic shot of Jerry Garcia.
And this was a photographed for
a magazine called "The Golden
Road," which was a Grateful Dead
fanzine that everybody loved.
And I shot this up
at the Grateful Dead
office in San Rafael in 1991.
And it was a little,
little, tiny office,
I mean, literally, from
like here to that wall.
And I had to sit on the desk.
And I was, like, you
know, this close to Jerry.
And the publicist was outside.
And I started shooting, and
I shot for about 15 seconds.
And he came in and
said, OK, you're done.
And I'm like, no, and
I, literally, just-- I
didn't shoot any
medium format, which
is a Hasselblad
square format, which
are those square photos
you saw from "BAM" covers.
And I shot like a roll and
a half of black and white,
as fast as I could, and
about 10 frames in color.
And then I was out, and he
went off and did the interview.
You know, most of these guys--
Jerry Garcia, Carlos Santana,
Neil Young, people that I've
been working with now for 15,
20, 25 years-- they've
done hundreds, hundreds,
hundreds of photo shoots.
But every time I go to a photo
shoot with Neil or Carlos,
whoever, like I want
to be brilliant.
I need to be-- because I'm only
as good as my last photograph.
Who cares that I shot
Jerry Garcia in 1991.
The photo editors I'm working
with today are art directors.
They want to see
what I did yesterday.
And so, I want to do the
best photograph I can.
They just want to
leave and go eat lunch,
or have a turkey sandwich.
They don't really care.
They've been there,
they've done that, they've
been doing it for
their whole career.
This is a Jerry Garcia
puppet from a video
they were making down
in Monterrey in 1987,
in May of '87.
And I'm in this video,
"Touch of Grey" video.
If you go on YouTube, you can
see me dancing down front.
Again, I'm the guy
with the mullet.
And all my friends were like,
we're going to be in the video.
And they ran and got
right in the center.
And I'm like, I'm going
to be over to the left.
It's a better angle
to photograph.
And I'm the one in the
video, and none of them are.
So, more Grateful Dead.
Bob Weir and Rob Wasserman--
Bob Weir with the Grateful Dead.
This is the first time I got
hired by a Grateful Dead member
to photograph them.
Bob was starting a
side project, which
was an acoustic duo
with Rob Wasserman.
And they needed new
publicity photos.
And so Bob's people
called me and hired me,
and for a couple
years, I was doing
a whole bunch of
different stuff with Bob.
He did a couple children's
books with his sister.
And these are like
for the jackets.
And you know, all the publicity
photos of Bob from about '90
to '93, '94 were all stuff
that I had shot of him.
This is for an ad for
that guitar company.
And another portrait
I did of Bob in 2003,
I believe this was, when
they were doing a tour.
This was a crazy day.
I woke up the day
before this photo shoot,
and I fell down on the
ground like with vertigo.
I was like all dizzy.
And so that day, I had to
drive up to the Dead warehouse
to scout some locations.
And I was like totally spun out.
And I drove up to Marin, and
I'm in the bushes outside
be Grateful Dead office just
throwing up in the bushes.
And I drive home
and I'm throwing up.
And then the next
day, I came and I
brought all these
extra assistants
in case I was going to
fall off the ladder.
And I did this whole big shoot
with the members of the Dead
for their 2000-- actually,
I think it was 2004-- tour.
But one of those weird moments.
This is one of the portraits
I did of Jerry the same day I
shot the Counting Crows cover.
We call this one "The Smoker."
This is one of the
most bootlegged
photos of the Grateful
Dead out there.
This was on the set
of a video that they
were filming for
"Throwing Stones," right
across the street in Oakland
from where I was living
at the time, actually,
and I just sort of walked
onto the set and pretended
I needed to be there all day
with them.
Way, way back, I actually took
that-- so somebody handed him
that Happy New Year
thing, somebody
wanted it for a
New Year's thing.
But I took a piece of paper, and
some rubber cement, and a razor
blade, and covered
it, and then wrote,
"I need a miracle
ticket" in hand writing.
This was pre-computers.
And that photo's been bootlegged
everywhere in the world.
One of my other photo
sessions with Jerry, in 1992.
This is from the same one
as the Counting Crows day.
And of course, because I
had all this great stuff
on the Grateful Dead, I had to
do a book on the Grateful Dead.
This is my first book
that I published.
And this was in 2002.
I start working on the contract
for this in the summer of 2001.
And we signed a contract
about a week before 9/11/2001.
And of course, when 9/11 hit,
the phone stopped ringing,
there was no more
business, and this book
saved my career, or
at least my business,
because they gave me an upfront
advance and upfront production
money.
I had one employee
and he stayed on,
and we produced this book,
which came out in 2002.
But that gave me the bug
to really do another book.
And so, now we're
back to Primus.
Another thing that's
always been important to me
is being able to work with a
band for a long period of time.
Because A, it shows
that they trust
you and they respect
what you're doing.
But I think, again, from the
visual anthropology standpoint,
it's a real great study.
And so Primus is
a band that I've
been working with since
1990 on a regular basis.
And I did a book on them.
After I dead my
Grateful Dead book,
I had a bug, like I
wanted to do another book.
And I proposed this to
Les Claypool in Primus,
and we co-published it together.
Actually, I published it,
but we were partners on it.
And this was a
limited edition book.
You could only buy it on
the website-- their website
or my website--
it was $100 book.
They were all signed and
numbered by me and Les.
They come with an 8 by 10 print.
We still have a couple
hundred of them left.
But it was a very
successful book.
And just goes to
show that, if you
work with one artist for--
that's another "BAM" cover,
"Guitar Player" magazine cover.
A lot of my stuff I
was doing with them
was for magazine features.
And then, of course,
they were hiring me also.
Like, you know, here's someone
that's comfortable enough
to drop their drawers
at a photo shoot
and put a leaf in front of them.
Just, you know, Primus,
super, super creative people,
great references
to pop culture--
this is from a video
shoot that they did.
Remember those, were they
Ever-ready commercials,
or Duracell
commercials, remember,
where they have these costumes?
The same people built them these
costumes as those commercials.
This was one of
Les's solo projects.
This was a great idea that he's
like, I want to be in a frame.
And I came up with this
idea to put a frame
on a piece of white seamless,
and we cut it out and hung it,
and had him behind it.
Another one of Les's
solo projects--
that's the Frog Brigade.
More Primus.
And then the Primus book.
The Flaming Lips, another band
that I've done a lot of work
with.
This is my first shoot
with then, this is in 1989.
They were managed by a woman
who lived here in San Francisco.
And I'd never heard of them.
And she said she needed
a publicity shoot,
a little, alternative punk
rock band from Oklahoma.
And so we did a bunch
of shots of them.
And then they came back
a couple months later,
because they had a new
member of the band.
And so, this was right
after the earthquake in '89
that we shot this
second set of shots.
October of '89, I think
it was a week after that.
And he's in the back, Michael,
the bass player in the back,
is reading "Interview
With a Vampire."
And then I didn't see these
guys for four or five years.
And then I got assigned
by "Rolling Stone"
magazine to cover Lollapalooza,
when Lollapalooza still a
touring festival.
And for not the first year of
Lollapalooza, but the next five
or six years, I went to
the opening of Lollapalooza
no matter where it was in the
country for "Rolling Stone"
magazine.
And have any of you
guys seen The Flaming
Lips in the last couple years?
Do you know what their
stage show is like?
So this is their first thing.
And that scaffolding in the
back, with that guy on it,
has a bubble machine on it.
And that was their
first stage prop.
If you don't know what their
stage shows look like now,
go online and check it out.
It's completely out of control.
But this was sort
of the beginning
of all of that madness.
And this is the shot that
ran in "Rolling Stone."
Just one of those great shots.
So you have Wayne, this
is from the soft bulletin,
I did the publicity
photos for that.
This is sort of what their new
show looks like-- actually,
their newest one's a little
bit different-- but you know,
they would bring up audience
members to dance on stage.
So this is just some
random audience member.
They would put them in costumes.
They have people on either
side of the stage dancing.
I brought my son and my daughter
to the Yahoo Christmas party
like, I don't know, 10 year ago,
and The Flaming Lips played.
And they were dancing on
stage with animal masks
on their head.
This is at Bimbo's
from Noise Pop a year
or two ago when they played.
And of course, so
what did we do?
We did a book on
The Flaming Lips.
Wayne, the singer's,
wife-- actually, not wife.
They were never married.
His girlfriend at the time
is also a photographer.
And I was sort of mentoring her.
And so she had a lot of stuff.
I had a lot of stuff.
And we did this book.
Again, this is a
limited edition book.
You can't really
find it anymore.
It was only available on the
band's website, and Warner
Brothers website, and
I think Amazon had it.
But if you go on
Amazon and look at it,
it's got some glowing reviews.
And I've seen them floating
around for $500, $600,
$700 now.
Limited edition, signed
and numbered by the band.
So now we just get into a
bunch of portraits that I did.
This is The Indigo
Girls, right when
their very first
record came out.
Early Soundgarden-- I don't know
if you guys know this story,
but this guy over here,
Jason, he was in Nirvana.
And left Nirvana because
he wanted to be a rock star
and Soundgarden was bigger
than Nirvana at the time.
And he joined Soundgarden.
And then he left Soundgarden
because he was so depressed,
probably, for leaving
Nirvana, I don't
know, that he eventually
left the band.
But there was a
big article on him
recently in the New York Times.
I'll bet you can find it online.
He, like, joined the
army and became, like,
a special-- like a
Army Seal or something,
like super, super ranger dude.
And kind of left
rock and roll behind.
Jason Everman is his name.
So this is one of my early
shoots with Soundgarden.
And I did a whole bunch
of stuff with that.
Stone Temple Pilots-- this
was for a magazine story.
Radiohead, when their
first record came out,
do you remember their
first hit song, "Creep"?
That's when this was taken.
This was for "Us" magazine.
We shot this in San Francisco
at the Phoenix hotel.
You know, you can't even
talk to these guys anymore.
There's too many
people protecting them.
Then I shot them for
"Rolling Stone" magazine.
This is in the alleyway
right behind Slims.
They were playing
Slims that night.
After we did this
photo shoot, they all
came over to my studio, which at
the time was at 9th and Folsom,
to look at a bunch of
photos I had taken of them.
Doing a free, live concert--
you probably don't know this,
but Radiohead did a free,
live concert in San Francisco
at Justin Herman Plaza in 1995.
More shots-- that's this
is taken with a four
by five camera with Polaroid
film that has a negative also.
A '95 portrait.
This was my next
shoot, I think in '96.
This was done for
"Addicted to Noise,"
which was the first
online music magazine.
Also at the Phoenix hotel.
This is REM.
This was shot down at
the Chateau Marmont
down in Los Angeles.
And it was a magazine cover
for a German magazine.
And I set this shot up
right here for the cover.
And Michael Stipe would not
put his bag down for me.
And I had a 20-minute slot.
And I sat down and I
shot my cover shot.
And you can see this
is a square format
image-- this is shot
with a Hasselblad, which
is what we used to shoot most
of our magazine covers with--
and I shot for like
four or five minutes.
Was getting ready to move
them to the next spot,
and I turned to the publicist,
I go, "We're doing great.
That was five minutes.
We've got 15 to go."
And she looks at me, she goes,
"Honey, that was 15 minutes.
You have five minutes to go."
And I was like, woah.
So I just like
went into high gear
and did a quick available
light shot facing
the other direction.
Then moved them to a window for
the last shot, and I was done.
Another shot of the Indigo Girls
for a cover of "Acoustic Star"
magazine, also shot in
the alleyway behind Slims.
I shot in every,
single back alley
in San Francisco,
and every warehouse.
And you know, if you
guys know the city at all
or live in the city, the
Dogpatch neighborhood
was like my photo studio.
There were so many great,
dilapidated warehouses.
And I'd go do a photo
shoot, come back,
and the warehouse would be gone.
So my whole stomping grounds.
I don't know where all the
young photographers are
going to shoot all
the cool bands now,
because there ain't
no places left.
You've got to go to Oakland.
Soundgarden at Lollapalooza '92.
Same thing, this was shot
for "Rolling Stone" magazine.
Booker T and the MGs-- did
Duck Dunn just die, did I hear?
You know, the bass player?
Blues Traveler-- this was
shot for their record, "Four."
I did the CD packaging for that.
It's on A&M. That was their
big, hit record, which
I think they're doing a
25-year anniversary of it,
coming up next year.
The worst CD package ever in
the history of CD packages.
Just terrible,
terrible, terrible
because the singer got a big
fight with the record company
about how big the
lyrics should be.
And they just kind
of screwed them
and just did a really bad job.
I don't know if guys remember
The Squirrel Nut Zippers.
I shot two albums for them.
They're from North Carolina.
Actually, I was
nominated for a Grammy
for one of these
for CD packaging.
The band Phish, shut down
at Shoreline right down
the street here.
The Donnas-- they were a
Palo Alto band and they
started out as young
teenagers in high school.
And we went to this abandoned
high school in Palo Alto
and shot them in the bathroom.
Because that's where bad
girls in Palo Alto hang out,
in the bathroom.
The Talking Heads-- so I'm a
huge Talking Heads fan, always
have been.
In 1992, I went and
saw The Talking Heads
on the "Stop Making
Sense" tour, which
was the movie that
Jonathan Demme-- right?
That's who directed
that, right?-- did.
And this was taken for the
15th anniversary of that movie.
They were doing a
thing at the Castro
Theater in San Francisco.
But when I went and saw them in
'92, I didn't have any money.
I was in college and
tickets were like $12.
And so we made
counterfeit tickets.
But back then, the way
we did it is we took--
we Xeroxed them in
black and white--
they were theatre tickets, not
like Ticketron or Ticketmaster
or whatever it is, they
were like theater tickets--
we photocopied them
in black and white.
Then we watercolored them
with watercolor paints.
And then we glued a
bunch of pieces of paper
together until they were
about the right thickness.
And then perforated
them with a pen.
And it worked.
We all got into the show,
like four or five of us,
we snuck in.
And so, when I did this
shoot with these guys,
David Byrne got there first.
And these guys don't like
each other, or at least Chris
and Tina, who are
husband and wife,
never really got
along with David.
They all got there separately.
So David got there
and I told him
the story about making
the counterfeit ticket.
And I go, so, I guess
I owe you 10 bucks.
And I whip out $10
to give it to him.
He's like, no, that's OK, dude.
You don't have to pay
me for the ticket.
This is the only band photo that
has been taken of The Talking
Heads since they broke up
back in the early '90s.
It was all taken at the
Miako Hotel up in the city.
This is from a
photo shoot that I
did with a bad called Lag
Wagon-- punk rock band out
of San Francisco, great
band-- and these were all
band members.
And we dressed everybody up
like they were from the '50s.
You know, the teacher, you know,
warning signs of communists,
long hair on men,
short hair on women.
The gas station attendant,
of course the milkman,
and Joey again.
And the whole band.
This picture has
great meaning to me.
This is the Doobie Brothers, and
I did their publicity photos.
This is in my old
studio south of Market.
And the Doobie Brothers was
my very, very first concert,
when I was in ninth
grade in 1975.
Halloween night, 1975,
Madison Square Garden,
I went and saw The
Doobie Brothers.
So when I had them in my
studio, I was like, hey,
you guys were my first concert.
I had good taste in music back
then, and still hopefully do.
But just one of those moments
that you're with somebody
that you've been along
that ride with for so long.
Third Eye Blind-- this
is actually a still
from a video we were shooting.
I did a whole video--
you can find it online,
on YouTube-- of all
still photographs
with this kind of setting.
And it's all animated together.
There's like 6,000
still photographs.
The band Mo.
Smashmouth, who can't
get arrested these days,
but I shot all
their early albums.
And this is a publicity shoot
we just did a few years ago.
Turtle Island String Quartet--
this was done for them.
This is Furthur, the guys from
the Grateful Dead-- Phil Lesh
and Bob Weir-- you
know, here I was
16, 17-year-old
deadhead in New Jersey.
And 30 years later, I'm doing
their band publicity photos.
That's the drummer from
the Grateful Dead in a band
that he had called The
Seven Walkers, Blame Sally,
a band called ALO--
shot a couple albums
for them, Bay Area band.
Them again.
Yonder Mountain
String Band-- this
was shot up in the
Marin Headlands.
Trigger Happy with Joan Osborne,
shot in Golden Gate Park.
Mumford and Sons-- this
was shot down in Monterey,
two years ago, I
guess it was, when
they played that
festival down there.
And this is was for the cover
of "Acoustic Guitar" magazine.
And what was so
great about that is,
that night they were doing like
some sort of John Steinbeck
thing at some
theater in Monterey,
and they were playing
a Bruce Springsteen
song, "The Ghost of Tom Joad."
And they basically,
during my photo shoot,
they rehearsed it
for like 15 minutes
while I was just shooting them.
They just went over and over it.
You can't see it but my
iPhone is like right here.
I Photoshopped it out.
And they're like
reading the lyrics off
of my phone that was in that
shot while they were doing it.
And I was like, that's
great, because I wanted
pictures of them playing anyway.
Band call Materialized.
This is a cemetery up in
Oakland that I love to shoot in.
Just such a great, old cemetery
and I shot a lot of bands
there.
I asked permission once.
I was shooting the
band, Cake, there.
And we went and talked
to the cemetery director.
And he was like the
creepiest guy ever.
Like, I swear to God, like
when we left, we were saying,
he's got women locked up in
some of these tomb-like things.
It was that creepy.
Tim and Nicki Bluhm, Nicki
Bluhm and the Gramblers,
and The Motherhips.
Good friends of mine I've
done a lot of work with.
I just did this with
them not too long ago
for Yamaha guitars.
This is like a Yamaha
guitar marketing piece.
Huey Lewis and
the News, you guys
know the 1982 record,
"Sports" 30 years ago?
This is a reproduction that
we did of this last year.
So we went back to the
same bar in Mill Valley.
And I actually should have
put the original cover
in so you could see it.
So we recreated
that album cover.
Go up and look at
it online, you can
see the comparison
between the two.
But fun shoot.
Tea Leaf Green, shot in
Alameda for their new record.
The Deadly Gentleman,
a Bluegrass band.
The Shipp Twins from Portland.
This is something I just shot.
So this is real
contemporary work.
I think that, as a
photographer, it's
so important to stay relevant.
I've been doing this
a really long time.
And I know a lot
of photographers
that are my age that have
been doing it for a long time,
they don't shoot anymore.
And I think that,
for me, it's always
been important to remain
relevant and not be a relic.
And to be able to keep shooting.
And I feel like work like
this-- I love this photograph.
Personally, I just think
it's a stunning photograph
of two stunning women
that are twin sisters.
But I'm still trying to
continue to reinvent myself
as a photographer in
the digital world.
Because I went from very
analog to very digital.
Neil Young, another one
of my favorite subjects.
This was shot for the cover
of "Pulse" magazine, which
was "Tower Pulse" when
Tower Records was around.
And this was shot
a couple of days
after Bill Graham died
in the helicopter crash.
And a couple days before they
did the big memorial show
for him in the park.
And I have a lot
of Neil in here.
Neil is a very, very,
very, very intense person.
If you've ever been
around Neil, you
know that he is the
epitome of mad genius.
And I was told that
I was going to have
10 minutes to photograph
him for this cover.
And he was telling me
my 10 minutes was up.
And so, it was pretty funny.
So we shot him in
the train room.
You know, he lives
down here in Woodside.
And he has this room
that-- you know,
he was part owner of
Lionel trains for a while.
I don't know if he still is.
And he had a train room.
And it was just this
giant room-- probably
twice the size of this room--
with this giant train track
and these ceilings
that were painted
with clouds and mountains.
And it was just this
incredible thing.
And we found this little corner
that hadn't been painted yet,
and we shot him
there for the cover.
And then I convinced
them to go outside and do
one other shot with me outside.
This was from the same shoot.
And then we were done.
This is from
another shoot that I
did for another magazine,
"Musician" magazine.
Do you guys know what
the Mountain Home is, up
on Skyline Boulevard?
It's a restaurant up there.
So he was doing a bunch of
press for all sorts of stuff.
And I was told to be
there at a certain time.
I'm tooling down Skyline
Boulevard at 50 miles an hour.
And all of the sudden, the
Mountain Home comes up,
and I hit the brakes, and
pull into the parking lot,
and it's all gravel.
And I'm screeching and skidding.
And he's doing a video interview
with Kurt Loder from MTV.
And the producer guy comes
running over and he's like,
"shh."
And you know, I'm like,
OK, dude, whatever.
You know, I'm here, I stopped.
And so, they finish
their interview.
And again, I'm told I have 10
minutes to photograph Neil.
So I sit him down.
And this is still shooting film.
And I shoot a picture
with a Polaroid back,
which tests your lighting.
And it takes 90 seconds
to develop, right?
So I pull the
Polaroid, Kurt Loder
comes back and start
talking to Neil,
10 minutes goes by
I'm like waiting.
The publicist comes back
and goes, "OK, you're done."
I'm like, "I only
shot a Polaroid.
That's it.
I'm not done."
And he looks at Kurt and he
goes, "Kurt, get out of here.
Neil, sit down."
And I shot for my 10 minutes.
And I did three set ups.
This was the last one.
This is shot with a
high-contrast, high-grain,
black-and-white Polaroid
film called Polagraph.
And it has 12
frames on the role.
And it's so sensitive to light
that you have to bracket.
And you usually only
get three frames
that are correctly
exposed out of the roll.
That's one of the portraits
from that shoot, where
he was sitting down.
This is a shoot I did
for "Esquire" magazine.
This is backstage at
Shoreline Amphitheatre
during one of the
Bridge School benefits.
Another one of those
things where I, literally,
had five minutes.
And that's the
guitar case that was
given to him by Hank
Williams's granddaughter.
And he has Hank
Williams's guitar.
And his guitar tech
told me where the guitar
was in this trunk
in this big truck.
And I had my son with me at
the time, who was probably,
I don't know, 11 or 12.
And so I told Sam, my
son, "Go get that guitar
case that I showed you."
He comes walking out with
Neil's Hank Williams guitar.
And Neil looks and him and
he goes, "I'll take that."
Pretty classic moment.
But I love working with Neil.
And you know, one of these
days I'll do a book on him.
But I think I have to wait until
a little bit further along.
This is my most recent
portrait that I did of Neil.
I was asked to do a
visa photo for him,
because he was traveling to
Brazil a couple years ago.
Because Neil can't just
walk into Walgreen's
and do a visa photo.
And so I did it for
him, his manager,
and two crew guys that
were going with him.
And so, we set up backstage at
Shoreline in the Bridge School.
And you're not allowed to
wear a hat for a visa photo.
And he didn't shave.
And you're supposed
to be straight
onto the camera and
all these things.
He sat for me for about,
literally, maybe 60 seconds.
And he's like, "You got it?
You got it?"
And I'm like, "One more."
He goes, "OK."
And he grabs this
hat and looks at me.
And I take one shot, and
he gets up and walks away.
And that was the.
Shot.
So that's the only one without--
that's not the visa photo,
but I just love that picture.
Ken Kesey-- so this is a
section on photographs of people
that I've shot that
are not musicians.
Ken Kesey wrote "One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest"
and "Sometimes a Great Notion"
Merry Pranksters, Acid Tests
with the Grateful Dead,
et cetera.
Anybody know who Anton LaVey is?
The Church of
Satan, you guys ever
hear of The Church of Satan?
Look it up on Wikipedia.
And this was shot in his
basement in San Francisco.
Very interesting.
This room here was called
the den of iniquity.
And the church of Satan was
basically all about sex.
As you can see, the mannequin
Cub Scout with the erection.
And the drunk woman passed out.
And it's a whole thing.
Anton LaVey with his pentagram.
This was a fashion
shoot, by the way,
that we did with him for
"The Nose" magazine which
is sort of like "The
Onion" in print.
Allen Ginsberg, the beat poet.
Lemony Snicket--
Daniel Handler-- this
was shot at the Palace of Legion
of Honor up in San Fransisco.
It's a four by five Polaroid.
Shaquille O'Neill--
did this in LA.
He was making one of those
bad movies that he made.
And he had a giant penthouse
with no furniture in it.
Like, he didn't
really live there.
He was just staying
there during the filming.
And he had this
big Superman ring.
It doesn't look that big, but
when I put it on my fingers,
I think it covered
three of my fingers.
Latrell Spreewell-- remember
when he was on the Golden State
Warriors and he
choked the coach?
I shot this for "The Source"
magazine at that time.
Bill Clinton-- he
was still president.
This was at the Presidio
in San Francisco.
And they were
turning the Presidio
over to the city
of San Francisco.
And there was
governors and senators
and-- I was shooting for
the GGNRA-- which is not
the National Rifle Association,
which is the Golden Gate
National Recreation Area-- and
I needed to be on the beach
when he was walking on the
beach with the GGNRA director.
And they only let one
photographer up there.
It was a pool photographer
from Time Magazine or whatever.
And I'm like talking to
my ranger contact, who's
talking to the Secret Service.
And they finally
let me on the beach,
and I make it like
four steps, and I'm
in a headlock by
the Secret Service.
OK.
And so anyway, I got the
shot and survived that one.
I'm going to go fast,
because I think I only
have about 10 minutes,
and then we're
going to go into
question and answers.
Is that correct?
OK, oh, wow, times is flying.
These are a bunch
of ads that we shot
for different publications,
or different ad companies.
This was great.
We got to rent an elephant.
Steve Ballmer-- you guys know
who Steve Ballmer is, right?
OK.
I was doing a lot
of stuff, but then I
was asked to
photograph, in 1995,
a little company called Yahoo.
They had just incorporated
a few months before that.
And this is Filo and Yang in
their office at Yahoo in 1995.
They had 20 employees.
This was shot for
"Rolling Stone" magazine.
That is their
entire data center.
OK?
So then a couple of years
later, in October of '99,
I was hired by
"Fortune" magazine
to shoot a brand new
company called Google.
There were 80 employees here.
We shot Sergey and Larry.
And then we shot them in
front of the company car.
OK, there were no jets,
but we did shoot them
in front of-- that
was the Google car.
And that was in '99.
This is Carlos Santana, the
back cover of Supernatural.
And again, Carlos is someone
I've done a lot of work
with over the years.
And one of these days, I'll
do a big book on Carlos,
but not quite yet.
This was just taken at Jazz
Fest just a few weeks ago,
or two weeks ago.
John Fogerty for
"Rolling Stone" magazine.
He was on trial for a
plagiarizing his own music.
Shot for "Rolling
Stone" magazine.
This is a band called Minus
5, which is the guys from REM.
And the art director said, bring
your axes, bring your guitar,
bring your axes.
So they brought their axes.
BB King-- this was shot for the
cover of "Fret Board" magazine.
BB wanted me to shoot him
in this little back area
of his bus, and I
was like, no way.
So I convinced
him-- when he came
offstage, I had a room-- it was
in Paramount Theater in Oakland
and I dragged him into
this room very quickly.
I'm going to try and-- Brian
Wilson, from the Beach Boys.
It's a great story,
but I'm not going
to tell it because
we don't have time.
David Byrne-- another one.
He came to my studio
for a photo shoot.
This was also for
"Addicted to Noise."
And he rode up on his
bicycle with his bike helmet.
And he rang the doorbell
and my assistant at the time
thought he was a bike messenger
and handed him a package.
He said, "No, no, I'm David.
I'm here for a photo shoot."
But, you know.
Dr Dre-- this is right after
he left Death Row Records
and there was a hit put
out on him by Suge Night.
And he had 20 guys surrounding
him everywhere he went.
And he didn't like the wardrobe
that we had picked out.
So he disappeared with his
entourage for three hours
to go up to Melrose.
This is after, actually, me
flying to LA the night before
and him cancelling the shoot
because he was too tired from
a all night session.
He came the next day.
They went shopping on
Melrose for four hours
and got a black t-shirt,
which we had nine of.
And so we shot him.
This is when some art director
at "The Source" magazine
decided that the nice,
white, Jewish kid should
be the next cool
hip-hop photographer
and shoot cover
for "The Source."
Perry Farrell from
Jane's Addiction--
this is from a "BAM" magazine
cover with his then wife.
They were editing a concert
film in their hotel room.
More Jane's Addiction.
This is Me First and
the Gimmee Gimmees,
which is a San Francisco
punk rock super group that I
shot a bunch of
album covers for.
That's their most
recent album cover
that just came out in the last
couple weeks called "Divas."
Michael Hedges, which
is another great story.
If you know who
Michael Hedges is,
he's an incredible
guitar player who
is known for his
incredible guitar
playing and his
long, flowing hair.
I did two photo shoots
with him, six years apart.
And both shoots, he
shaved his head three days
before the shoot.
And he died in a horrible
motorcycle accident
riding home to Monterey.
Alkaline Trio, shot
in that same cemetery.
And of course, we
came by a grave
that they were just digging,
so I jumped down in the grave
to photograph them.
Roger McGuinn, from The Byrds.
I shot this in high
school, April 14, 1979.
And just by chance,
April 14, 2004,
he was in my studio shooting
for a magazine cover.
So 25 years to the day.
I was anal.
Back when I was a
kid, I kept track
of the exact date of
everything I shot.
Which is so important.
I know so many photographers
that don't do that.
Aaron Neville from the Neville
Brothers, down in New Orleans.
We shot a bunch of album covers
for him for his gospel records.
The Barenaked Ladies--
became good friends of mine.
This is the shoot that we did
for their record, "Stunt."
and this is Kevin, the
keyboard player, who
had been feeling sick with
the flu for about two weeks
leading up to this photo shoot.
When he was getting
off the plane,
something fell out of the
overhead, hit him in the head
and he was gushing with blood.
And you know how with head
wounds, you bleed a lot anyway.
We did the photo shoot,
he was really exhausted,
really wasn't feeling well.
He flew back to
Toronto the next day
and they diagnosed
him with Leukemia
and said he had
six months to live.
This was in 1999.
He's still alive today,
which is pretty remarkable.
That's the shot that's
on the album, on the CD.
Tom Waits-- all right, we have
time for one good Tom Waits
story.
This isn't the first
time that I shot
Waits, which was
in August of '92,
for "The Bone Machine" record.
And I'm not going
to tell this story.
I'm going to tell
the next story.
So the next time I was asked
to photograph Tom Waits
was in 1999.
And we went back up
to the same place.
This is a recording
studio called Prairie Sun
up in Cotati, where he
records his records.
And it's a chicken farmer.
There's chickens running
around everywhere.
And there's old, abandoned
motorcycles and claw tub
bathtubs.
And I would walk
around, and I said,
you know, I said-- there was
old, wrought iron furniture.
And I sat Tom down, and I said,
"Let's shoot the cover here
on this."
He goes, "Jay, this furniture
looks like it could be
my grandmother's."
So I brought him over
to the motorcycle
and he wouldn't let
me-- I brought him
to the claw foot bathtub.
He wouldn't let me
shoot him there.
Go to the motorcycle,
I'm freaking out
because I only have like
30 minutes to do the shoot.
He's like, "No, I
don't like this."
And then I bring him
to this spot here.
And I say, "Let me do a
shot of you sitting there."
And he's like, "No,
let's do it standing up."
I go, "Let's do a Polaroid--
standing up or sitting down."
I show him the
Polaroid standing up.
He goes, "Jay, you're right.
Looks better sitting down,
but just watch my chin."
So then, finally, he
goes, "I got an idea.
Let's jump in my car and go
just two miles down the road,
because there's this old,
abandoned car that I saw.
And we'll take some
photographs there."
So we jump in his car.
And he's looking at me.
He goes, "Do you remember the
old Woody Woodpecker thing
from the '60s?"
He was like, you know, making
that face at me, right?
I'm like, yeah.
So it was just me
and him in the car.
And he's like, "It's just
three minutes down the road."
Well, we went from
Cotati to Petaluma,
which took 30
minutes to get there.
So we're driving down
all these back roads.
And he's like, "Jay, I think
we're going to run out of gas."
Right?
And I'm thinking, "OK,
well that's great.
Let's stop and get gas.
I'll take pictures
of you pumping gas."
"There ain't no gas
stations between here and.
Petaluma."
So we get down there.
And he gets out of
the car, his truck,
and he goes, "I don't
know whose house this is
and I don't know
whose car that is,
but you'd better go
and to ask and see
if we can take pictures there."
So I go up and
ring the doorbell.
Nobody answers, nobody answers.
Finally, we're walking
up the driveway
and this little lady comes out.
And I say, "Hey, can I
take some photographs
in the car in the back?"
And she goes, "Car?
It's got no wheels."
I'm like, "No, no, no, no, no."
And I've got, like, three
cameras around my neck.
Because when we left
the chicken ranch,
I didn't bring any equipment.
No lighting equipment.
Just all my cameras.
I looked like Dennis Hopper
in "Apocalypse Now," right?
And so, I have all these
cameras around my neck.
And I go, "No, no, no.
We don't want to drive the car.
We want to take a photograph
of my friend, Tommy, here."
She goes, "Car hasn't driven
since my husband died in '62."
You know?
And like, I mean, is
this like Tom Waits's,
like, everyday life?
And she's got like a scarf
wrapped around her head.
And this long trench
coat, you know?
So finally, I go,
"Can I give you $25?"
I write it on a piece of paper.
I will give you
$25 to use the car.
And I showed her.
She's like, "I don't
want your money."
Right?
So we go over, we
hop over the fence,
and we shoot all these photos.
And Tom's pretending that
he's a used car salesman.
And then he says, "Take a
picture of me by the grill,
because it looks like my face."
So we're shooting all these
pictures of him down there.
And this whole thing--
you know, here he is,
"You want to buy a car?"
You know, doing all the
stuff with Tom, right?
And then he goes,
"OK, I got to go."
I'm like, "No, no, no.
Wait.
One more roll."
And I break out my
toy, plastic camera
that's in the Google colors.
You ever seen like a little--
what are those things called?
What's that?
No, not a LEGO.
I'll think about it.
It's a low-mo type camera.
Anyways, it's
literally, it's green
and yellow and red and blue.
And it's plastic and it takes--
and it has a lens that spins.
And you get four
frames at once, right?
And it's plastic.
And it's out of focus.
And so I'm like shooting
Tom with the plastic camera.
And he's hanging out.
And then he goes,
"OK, I got to go."
And he jumps over there
the barbed wire cow fence
and starts running
down the driveway.
And I'm chasing after him
with a 1960s Polaroid.
You know, shooting and
running, and pulling Polaroids,
and dropping them
on the driveway.
And he gets to the car and
he looks at me and goes,
"OK, see you later."
And he drives away.
And we were being followed by my
assistant in the publicist car,
so there was another car there.
And he just drives away.
And I'm like, OK.
We get back in the car, drive up
to Cotati, get all of our stuff
that we just left scattered
everywhere on the property--
four by five camera, lighting
equipment, everything--
and packed up.
And that was the end of
my shoot with Tom Waits.
So let's see.
And there's one
of the Polaroids--
one of the last Polaroids.
It was a Polaroid that
had a negative, also.
Ben Harper-- Jared, are we done?
Dave Matthews-- you know
what, I'm going to go fast.
Bob Scagg,s Emmylou Harris,
George Clinton, James Brown,
Johnny Cash and June Cash,
Joni Mitchell, Josh Groban--
I shot his first album cover.
That's the cover,
although they used it
in black and white--
Siouxsie Sioux
from Siouxsie and the Bansees,
Snoop, Snoop smoking pot.
Snoop passed out in the
middle of his photo shoot.
And he said, he
goes, "Hey, man, I'm
known for passing out
in my photo shoots."
Steve Miller, Tori Amos--
her first magazine cover,
cover of "Keyboard" magazine--
Chris Isaac, Waylon Jennings,
Jello Biafra, The Neville
Brothers down in New Orleans,
Gil Scott Heron, Ike
Turner as in Ike and Tina,
JJ Cahill who just
died last year,
Country Joe McDonald,
Fiona Apple--
who is as depressed
as her picture looks.
Jamie Foxx, the actor.
I shot his first album cover.
OK?
And after the shoot was over,
we were talking about ping-pong.
He's like, "I got a ping
pong table at my house.
Let's go play ping-pong."
So we go to his house.
He's in the flat
lands of Hollywood.
This is before "Ray,"
before he was a big--
and I'm pretty
good at ping-pong.
Like I can hold my own.
And he destroyed me.
He was like Olympic-level
ping-pong player.
But shot Jamie's first album.
Isaac Hayes, Michael Penn, Bob
Mould-- this was done in 1990,
and I just did Bob Mould's
new album three months ago,
25 years later-- Chris
Whitley, John Lee Hooker,
John Lee Hooker, Hooker,
Hooker, Jorma, Taj Mahal--
that's for an album cover.
And then I did a book
called "Travelling on a High
Frequency," which is
also out here, which
was all of the stuff
that you just saw.
Some new work that
I did recently.
This is all digital work.
Peter Rowan-- we're almost done.
We've only got a few more to go.
Eddie Money, Chris
Robinson-- that
was a magazine cover-- Elvis
Costello at Hardly Strictly
Bluegrass, Emmy Lou Harris,
Jackie Greene, Jackie
Greene, Rambling Jack Elliott,
Essence, Josh Redman--
shot his last record-- Phil
Lesh from the Grateful Dead.
And that's the cover
of my new book, "JAM,"
which is all the live stuff,
which is available for sale
out here.
And that's all live
concert photography.
All right, I think we're going
to go into some questions here.
Allman Brothers, and
Carlos, Elvis Costello,
Government Mule, Jackie
Greene, Jane's Addiction-- this
is all stuff that's
in my new "JAM" book.
I really wanted to do a book--
I'm going to tell one more fun
story because this
is a good one.
So this was shot at the
Bridge School Benefit.
This is Eddy Vedder and Neil
Young at the Bridge School.
Epic photograph, right? "Rolling
Stone" ran it full page.
When you opened the magazine,
it was the first photo.
They took where it
said Bridge School
and they put their little
circle there and wrote RS
with the issue
number that they do.
So the next year, I'm
back at the Bridge School.
And I've been shooting
the Bridge School
for 25 years for Neil and Peggy.
And I walk up to Eddie
and I introduce myself.
And I say, "Hey, I'm the guy
that took that picture of you
and Neil that was
in "Rolling Stone."
And he goes, "Oh, I
love that picture.
Can I get a copy?"
I go, "Yeah."
He goes, "But I've got
to tell you a story.
You know that scarf that
I'm wearing in that?"
He goes, "You know the
actor Bradley Cooper?"
I'm like, "Well,
I know who he is.
Like, I'm not hanging
out with Bradley Cooper."
He goes, "Well, Bradley
Cooper called me up
and needed a favor.
He needed me to, like,
autograph some things
for some friend of his
or relative or whatever.
And I'm like, sure, no problem."
So, Eddie autographs some CDs
or prints, whatever it was,
sends them to Bradley Cooper.
And in exchange,
Bradley Cooper sends him
this scarf, right,
as a thank you.
So then, this shot
is in "Rolling Stone"
and Bradley Cooper sees it.
And calls Eddie and goes,
"I really miss that scarf.
Can I have it back? "
And Eddie was like, "Fuck, no."
So Eddie told me that story,
which is a great story.
Neil Young from his
"Last Electric" tour.
Fish at Red Rocks, String
Cheese at Red Rocks,
Spearhead-- another one
of my favorite bands.
I've been working with
Michael Franti and Spearhead
since the late '80s.
I do a lot of video-- The
Roots, Kirk from The Roots
has become a good friend--
My Morning Jacket,
who's on the cover
of the new book.
Black Keys, before
anybody really
knew them, playing at a small
festival on the East Coast.
This is Mo at Red
Rocks, Gogo Bordello--
and I think we're
just about done.
I've got like five more.
Grace Potter, Lukas Nelson, the
Avett Brothers at Mountain Jam.
And then I got a lot of
crowd shots in there.
And that's because I'm going
to do my next book, which
is going to come out
in 2015, and that's
going to be called
"Hippie Chick."
And it's going to be exactly
what you think it is.
Hippie chicks.
And what a long strange
trip it continues to be.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAY BLAKESBERG: Do we have
time for a couple of questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, do
you have any stories
about the '70s scene of like
Jackson Browne, and Tom Petty,
and people in the LA area.
JAY BLAKESBERG: Not
really, because I was still
in high school in the '70s.
And so, I mean, I've been
face to face with those guys.
And Jackson, I love
Jackson, and I've
photographed him many
times over the years.
But not really from the '70s.
I was still a kid
with a camera, trying
to figure out my
place in the script.
AUDIENCE: What's your
favorite venue to shoot in?
And then, also,
what musician have
you seen evolve the
most over the years
that you've been able to shoot?
JAY BLAKESBERG: You know, I
like shooting in smaller-- like,
as far as festivals go,
I like smaller festivals.
I like Mountain Jam and
Summer Camp and Moedown
and Gathering the Vibes--
these are East Coast festivals.
Like I don't love big you
know, 90 bands over 17 stages.
Like at JazzFest
where I was last week,
you know, when Carlos
Santana was playing,
I was on stage shooting him.
I do a lot of work with him.
And I stayed for the whole set.
And most people that are at
JazzFest that are shooting,
it's 15 minutes here,
it's 15 minutes here, it's
15-- and I don't like that.
I like the-- like
the way you get
the epic photograph is you
wait for the photograph.
It just doesn't happen
in the first 15 minutes.
And so, on the festival side,
I like smaller festivals.
And I like to be
able to concentrate
on staying in one place
as long as possible.
Venue-wise, I mean, I
love all the-- I love
Slims and the Great
American Music Hall,
and The Fillmore, and The
Warfield, and The Fox,
and all the--
Terapin Crossroads,
I love shooting at
Terapin Crossroads--
and the Sweetwater.
I mean, there's so many
great venues in the Bay Area.
I like venues with low stages.
And that's why I like
shooting on stage a lot.
And I've kind of
earned, or gotten
to the point where I'm
allowed to be on stage a lot.
Because you can
see people's feet.
When you're on a high
stage and you're shooting,
you seen them from here up.
And it's a different look.
And so, I like
being on stage, or I
like shooting in rooms
that have low stages, where
if I'm standing in front of
it, like I can see everything.
So what musician have I
seen develop the most?
You know, so many.
I mean, Primus, Michael
Franti in Spearhead,
you know, I think those are
people that have really-- you
know, when Spearhead
first started,
they were concerned
more of a hip-hop group.
And Primus was considered
a heavy metal band.
And now they're both darlings
of the jam bad world.
Because I think that fans
in the jam band world
are way more open-minded
than most other musical fans.
And really, if you
look at all the punk
rock that was happening in the
late '70s and stuff like that,
a lot of that stuff is
gone and disappeared.
But look at bands
like Moe and Fish,
that are 25 and 30
years into their career,
and they're still
vibrant, vibrant bands.
And so, even, like, Michael
Franti in Spearhead,
I first photographed him,
I think, in '87 or '88.
So long careers
that have evolved
into being who these people are.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I wonder if you
have a favorite perspective,
because I saw you shot,
like, a lot of fish eye.
JAY BLAKESBERG: So,
back in the day,
I did love the fish eye lens.
And I haven't really--
I don't have a fish
eye-- I do have a fish eye
lens-- but I never bring it
with me.
I shoot with a wide lens.
I have a 14 to 24 Nikon,
which I love and adore.
So it is a very wide lens,
but it's rectangular,
it's not curved at all.
Although it does stretch people
out on the ends, and makes
people look fat.
But I've always
been-- like my style,
and so, when you're
a photographer,
you're sort of
defined by your style.
At least, you should be
And I think a lot of
people don't have a style,
because they don't really
understand what they're doing.
And they picked up
a digital camera
and they're just shooting.
And so people used to
tell me all the time
they can tell my work, because
I always shot very wide.
And so, even my
live stuff-- like,
I know some photographers
that like to be far back
and shoot with long lenses
to get that compression--
but I like to be right
up front, like always
with a 24 millimeter
lens, or now my 14.
When I was shooting
prime lenses,
Nikon film, I think my
widest lens was a 20-- well,
I had the 16
millimeter fish eye--
but I would much prefer to be
right in your face shooting
then back.
It's just the style that I
liked and that I gravitated to.
AUDIENCE: So, how many photos
do you typically take at a show.
And how many of
those are the quality
that you would give to--
or, yeah, that were deleted.
JAY BLAKESBERG: So
I'm a heavy shooter,
and I always have been.
Even when I shot film,
I shot way more film
than everybody else.
Because I always
truly believed that,
if you're in front of
Jerry Garcia and its
September 1, 1985,
you're never going
to be at September
1, 1985 again.
So I've shot a lot of film.
And digital, I even shoot more.
Like a typical show,
especially if I'm
shooting the whole set--
like Santana at JazzFest,
I think I did 2,500 images in 90
minutes or something like that.
And that's pretty
typical for me,
to shoot about 2,500 images.
I typically delete 50%
of what I shoot, like,
pretty consistently.
I look at every single
photo that I shoot.
I have a full time
guy that works
for me that handles
all my digital IT,
and all my maintenance and re
touching and stuff like that.
And so our workflow, as it
all goes into his system,
and then I come in I edit it.
And it's sort of like, I work
in light room, so it's a delete
or a keep.
And if I'm keeping it,
I'm one starring it,
or two starring it,
or I'm rating it
so I can come back to it.
But I might deliver
to a client--
like if I'm shooting a band
like a publicity shoot,
I might try and get it down
to 200 or 300, out of like,
let's say 1,000 that I
might end up keeping,
or 800 that I'm
keeping that I'll
deliver to the client as a
web link for them to look at.
AUDIENCE: So I love the
old pictures of the hippies
at the dead shows, because I
see my old friends in them.
And I was wondering if
there's any way you could just
dump a huge library on
the internet somewhere.
JAY BLAKESBERG: Well,
go to my Facebook page.
There's hundreds of them--
Jay Blakesberg Photography.
AUDIENCE: Since you
started in film, obviously,
how do you feel about
having to transition
to digital with your workflow?
Do you feel like it's
affected your personal style
or improved it?
JAY BLAKESBERG: So, when the
transition-- so I was actually
a pretty early
adapter to digital.
Early on, we shot
film, but I've invested
in scanning technology, like
some of the early scanners.
And we would deliver our jobs
digitally to our clients.
And it was actually-- from
a business standpoint,
it was also good, because it
generated a lot of revenue.
Because at that time, clients
were still like, yeah,
we'll pay for
scanning, of course.
We used to pay for prints,
now we'll pay for scanning,
and we skip the-- you know, we
don't have to pay for prints
and then get the scans.
And so I have over-- I've
scan over 85,000 pieces
of film of mine that I shot.
I've probably shot over
a million images on film.
I've got over a million
images in my digital archive.
And so, when I first started
shooting with digital,
I hated it.
I hated the look.
It was also really
one of the reasons
why I stopped-- I never really
wanted to get into video.
I do a lot of video
directing, now,
because the technology has
changed to the point where
the look and feel
of it, creatively,
looks a lot like film, right?
24 frames per second,
stuff like that.
And so early digital
photography look like bad video
from the '80s, you know
bad soap opera video,
you know what I mean?
It had that look.
It was very sterile.
It was very pixel.
And you know, all the camera
manufacturers would be like,
you've got to shoot digital.
Look at how sharp this is.
Look at how many
pixels there are.
And I'm like, that's not--
You know when I used to shoot
film, I go out on a shoot
and I'd shoot color, I'd
shoot black and white,
I'd shoot fast film,
slow film, grainy film,
because that was sort
of what made the style.
Large format, medium
format, small format--
it was all those things
in the palette that
helped us create it.
So all the sudden, you
get a digital camera.
And everybody's taking
pictures, and it comes out
of the camera looking the same.
All of our pictures
are looking the same.
So I, early on, spent--
pre-Instagram filter land--
spent months, and
months, and months
with my IT digital re-toucher
guy developing like custom
filters that we created to
kind of make my digital photos
look like film.
And if you looked
at a lot-- it's
maybe hard to see on the screen.
But a lot of those images
that are shot digitally,
we would add grain, and
noise, and contrast,
and over-sharpening, and
all these different filters.
And we played around with
it for months and months
until we kind of came
up with a formula.
And so, until I kind of
came up with that look--
and if you pick up the book
"JAM" outside and look at it,
you'll see it in those
pictures, because they jump out
at you-- that's kind of
how I got to the point
where, creatively, I was
like, OK, I like this.
And it was also
the digital cameras
getting bigger files--
full sized chip
cameras made a difference.
And so, we were--
like I said, we
were early adapters to
digital, slow adapters
to using digital cameras,
because I didn't like it.
And I was a Nikon guy.
Canon was ahead of Nikon,
and the early Nikon cameras
were all small chip cameras,
and I hated the way it looked.
You know, like,
realistically, some
of the first photos
I took digitally
on those early cameras,
I kind of equate
them to like Instamatic
photos from the '70s.
Like that's how bad they are.
Like, they're garbage, really.
They're two, three,
four megabyte photos
that we didn't shoot raw.
Or if we did, they're just bad.
And we've lost digital files in
the transition in the migration
and whatnot.
You know.
But I like where I'm
at now, digitally.
And I think if you saw
some of the recent work
that I was showing, you can kind
of see where my style has gone.
And it doesn't look like it's
cookie cutter and off-the-shelf
and what everybody else does.
And I think that it
also has inspired
a lot of other
photographers that
do music, that know
me and know my work,
to try and go down
that same road.
JARED: Great, well thank
you very, very much, Jay.
JAY BLAKESBERG: Thanks,
Jared, for hosting me today.
Jared Kelly from
Google, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]